my name is Chris butcher and I'm one of
the engineering directors at Bungie
basically the format of this
presentation is going to be what I wish
I had known before we got started making
destiny we're gonna start with a little
bit of history and then we'll take a
tour through the development of the
tiger engine that powers Destiny we'll
talk about some lessons we learned along
the way and then we'll wrap up with a
discussion of the great struggle against
software complexity and why I believe
none of us can truly call ourselves
software architects anymore so just some
caveats before we get started I've
worked as an engineer at Bungie for 15
years I spend a lot of time talking to
people about game engines and I've also
spent lots of time evaluating other
people's game engines but I've only ever
worked at Bungie professionally so that
makes it kind of hard for me to have an
outside perspective on the stuff just
keep that in mind I am only one of a
very large number of engineers that
worked on destiny so I don't want to
take too much credit for this except
anything that's overly complicated that
is probably my fault and lastly this
presentation is just some subjective
thoughts of mine about the craft of
software architecture I'm gonna say some
things as fact but what I really mean is
that's my current best guess at an
overarching principle there are some
laws of software engineering but these
are not them so basically you should
take this whole presentation with a
metric ton of salt here's a million tons
of salt so let's start with a little bit
of history in 1997 Bungie started
working on Halo and a new engine that
powered it codenamed blam we used this
engine for all of the Halo games and
also Phoenix and gypsum which were two
game explorations built using the blam
engine but which did not see the light
of day the blam engine was a strong and
mature platform on which we built 10
years worth of features by about 2008 it
was starting to feel a bit old and it
isn't really due to an accumulation of
bad code or technical debt rather what
was happening is that a decade earlier
on the first Halo game we had set up the
initial design principles of the engine
which work really well back then but
they didn't apply as well to the modern
world
a single main thread a single platform
those are keys simplifying assumptions
back in 1997 but they start to become
restrictive and those kinds of
assumptions are also very hard to change
we could see it was going to be
increasingly difficult to compete in the
future so we started kind of thinking
about our engine this title is the title
of this talk is learning from the core
engine of distant what do I mean by the
core engine
it's my term for the framework on which
other engine features are built so the
stuff inside the lion the core engine
tends to be pretty tightly coupled and
its components usually called directly
into one another it's quite hard to
abstract them away from each other using
interfaces it's not because you can't
put an interface on some code of course
you can but rather there tend to be
shared assumptions assumptions about
data formats object lifetime state
management performance characteristics
or particularly multi-threading as one
example the resource manager and the
environment streaming system for an
engine tend to be designed together
because there are implicit rules about
heat how resources load and instantiate
into the engine as you move outside the
core I call the next layer up the
feature layer of the engine you know
there isn't really a hard distinction
about what's in the core layer or the
feature layer it's just a qualitative
term at a spectrum feature components
however tend to be more loosely coupled
camera systems pathfinding networking
rendering features these are almost
completely independent inside your
engine these feature components do talk
to each other they tend to talk through
interfaces so that they can be
abstracted but they tend to use data
formats object lifetimes interface
systems message protocols these are code
constructs that are defined by the core
components that underlie them so why is
that interesting and the reason it's
interesting is because these core
components have got shared assumptions
and these turn them to the unwritten
rules of your engine particularly things
like multi-threading and data lifecycle
every component of the engine everywhere
has to follow these rules and if it
doesn't it will be unstable or buggy or
just hard to work with because it
doesn't fit with what's around it and
engine code bases are really really
large these days so these rules become
very hard to change in a global fashion
you can extend the core components you
can add many many new features on top of
them but evolutionary change to these
properties of the core engine becomes
more difficult as the codebase size
increases so what are the rules of the
blam engine well we tend not to do
allocations from a global system heap we
do most of our allocations from
persistent pools in fact we try to have
zero usage of the system heap besides
the operating system it's a single
platform engine only Xbox and then has a
PC version that runs as an editor like I
said before there is one main thread all
the game logic and all the engine
systems assume they run on the main
thread except for i/o and operating
system which is asynchronous in Halo 3
we added a rendering thread that's great
but that was a very special purpose
thread only certain systems moved across
and again there were still assumptions
about what systems ran on which thread
one of the other big assumptions is that
there was a simple content pipeline what
I mean by simple well
there's both content like art audio
light maps or a nav mesh and that's
compiled those compilation stages are
all totally independent and unique for
each asset type but most of the game
content doesn't have an individual asset
compile process for example weapon data
doesn't get compiled before it loads
under the engine the development build
loads all of the content both the
compiled bulk assets and all of the
loose assets from individual loose files
which is pretty slow and this
development build that runs on the
console but then it can't usually run
your shipping levels because of memory
concerns so we have a cooking process
that builds the final console format and
that doesn't have an incremental update
in the blame engine so you have to run
it every time you make a single change
what this meant is that we ended up with
no system for patching content post
release another rule of the blam engine
is that game code is accessible from any
layer of the engine sounds great well
not really what that means is that it's
very hard for you to share code between
different game projects because your
ancient code ends up being tainted with
game logic for example when you mount
the utility drive should you format it
well if it's a single player yes if it's
a multi player level then none
so looking at these rules and looking at
the future in 2008 we can say well we're
a game engine's going what are trends in
the industry around this time
well multi-platform was a pretty big
imperative for us we also could see that
there was a new generation of consoles
coming soon at this point turned out to
be lighter than we thought and we also
thought well probably they'll have eight
to sixteen way symmetric multiprocessing
that's what pcs look like they're gonna
have we could also see there's a trend
towards heterogeneous computing
environments you have SPU's on the
PlayStation 3 and also the promise of
compute shaders and other things like
that you can look at other engines and
say hey a lot of those engines have got
really nice tools nicer than our tools
they have big unified editing
environments they can have many
different custom source formats each
with their own user interfaces that
provide a lovely place for artists to
work we would like to do something like
that and also in the future would really
like to be able to do multiple games in
one engine we've tried but it was very
very hard for us to share code between
those games because the rules I
mentioned so it's kind of late us the
questioner says hey is the blame engine
still relevant well it's probably still
relevant in 2010 is it relevant in 2015
what about 2020 you also have to look at
the competitive landscape back in 2009
there are three main factors first the
big games that are our competitors are
getting bigger more spectacle more
content more specialized art teams the
second factor is that there are small
games and these small games are on the
rise and competing for our business
indie teams or mobile games these people
can iterate rapidly and they're starting
to eat away at the niche that small
console games exist in in 2008 thirdly
when we look at the technology trends in
the future that I just mentioned it
seems as though the core assumptions of
our engine might start to hold us back
so all these factors led us to conclude
that we probably need to change
something about our engine technology if
we want to stay relevant ok so suppose
you've identified you need to make a
shift in engine strategy you have some
options to choose from maybe you can
license an engine that's a product with
continuous support like unreal or cry
engine remember unity wasn't around back
in 2008 you have the option here to go
and add your own core engine components
but in this scenario you're not going to
make changes to the core in
because if you change those core
assumptions that prevents you from
taking continuous integrations and it
means you can't receive support from the
engine provider another option is just a
branch from some other engine maybe it's
one that exists within your company or
perhaps an external company this model
isn't really favored as much these days
but back in the 1990s it was pretty
common for example within software's
engines or start from scratch this is
pretty rare in the modern age the only
documented example I know of starting
from scratch on a large engine is remedy
developing the Alan Wake Engine Marcus
Mackay gave a presentation about this on
GDC 2011 now this was a pretty focused
game it was a single player game a
single platform and they were able to
opt out of a lot of requirements that a
prison in a game like destiny also it
took about five years for them we
doesn't think that was really an option
for us at the time so pretty quickly we
settled on an evolutionary approach
there were big pieces of halo technology
that we knew we needed to preserve for
destiny specifically the gameplay
framework and the networking stack we're
just spent ten years solving the
problems of making a satisfying fast
action game in a networked world we just
didn't know if we could replicate it in
a new engine
we called this effort to evolve our
technology the tiger engine because we
had this cool piece of concept art for
DES made they had a space tiger in it
and what is more awesome than that so
after some months of evaluation and
technology planning we started the tiger
engine effort in the middle of 2008 we'd
identified some core principles we
wanted not technology it needs to be
pervasively multi-threaded and
cross-platform
we wanted to divide the codebase up into
layers so we could better decouple the
engine functionality from the game logic
and you know we were also pretty
idealistic we want all of the good
features of the blam engine and none of
the bad ones and we have all of these
great ideas for advanced technology we
just have to be able to do all of those
in this new engine a lot of these
principles were just theoretical goals
when we started and they became a lot
clearer over the course of development
so spoiler alert when we come to GDC
we're all looking for the real gritty
truth so I'm gonna try not to sugarcoat
anything about the development of
destiny
as you'd expect everything took longer
than we expected and we ran into some
really difficult times along the way
but it's not all negative we did a lot
of great work and ended up with some
really cool technology we have a new
engine that we think will last us for 10
more years it's cross platform and cross
generation so our designers can make one
game and then it just chips on all four
platforms and the final game is very
stable and very performant and it has a
lot of future potential for us to
exploit it was a rocky journey
developing all this technology but
despite all the difficulties we
encountered we think it was still worth
it
so now I'm gonna walk you through a
simplified timeline of the development
of destiny this isn't a post-mortem I'm
just going to provide just enough
context for us to discuss the
architectural lessons that we learned
along the way and I'm only going to talk
about the technology development I won't
touch at all on the art or design
concept development so in April 2008 we
begin by taking a branch of the Halo
codebase we start exploring ideas and
setting up the director to the tiger
engine it's a very small team as you can
see down there starting around August we
build a scripting environment for a game
play experimentation initially this is
using Lua moving into 2009 we start to
build the new cross-platform foundation
technology that the tiger core
components will be built on we do this
by extracting toolbox functionality from
the Halo Reach codebase and we start to
build new multi-threading primitives we
start a reflection system and a new
source content format that lets us break
ground at an entirely new content import
pipeline we also spin up multiple
independent efforts in feature research
and development so graphics pathfinding
animation and so on we also have
multiple new game prototypes going in
our new game plan script environment
these are kind of experimental gameplay
mods that at this point are running
inside the Halo Reach on top of all the
Halo Reach content by the end of the
year we have a few new components of the
tiger engine running inside this legacy
engine codebase and we also have a
number of standalone feature R&D code
bases this is what they look like in mid
2009 totally separate from any of our
engine work or gameplay prototypes this
is good because it allowed us to iterate
rapidly our potential features for
destiny without being dependent at all
on engine components that it didn't
exist yet in 2010 we began standing up
those core engine components this takes
quite a while in the middle of the year
there's a large hiatus when half of that
engineering team returns to go ship Halo
Reach
meanwhile we stand up the new level
import
we have a new editor framework this
requires all new importers for
environment geometry object system
gameplay all built in this new framework
and by the end of 2010 we have basic
test levels that can be authored in to
end all the way from source content now
editor through a new runtime resource
loader still loading as an implant
within the halo reach engine but the new
engine components are now mostly
connecting to each other rather than
connecting to the legacy engine that
surrounds them around about this time
the halo reach team joins the project
you can see a big jump in team size at
the beginning of 2011 many of the new
engine components are in a very partial
state most of the features you'd want to
do require a new core functionality to
be written to support them this means
our engineering efforts get a bit
fragmented multiple teams go off and
start working in their own separate R&D
code bases to get their work done well
in May we bring the first of those out
of R&D and into the mainline code base
with a new renderer and the environment
system at this point you can still run
the legacy game prototypes but they're
not compatible with the new renderer the
game prototypes continue for a few
months before we start to deprecated
them by August we have an onslaught of
new content being created with this new
pipeline and our systems are not scaling
to handle it we have to reboot the
content import pipeline to unblock our
content production I'll talk about this
more later on
starting in October we began development
of the PlayStation 3 foundation and
technology with a small team by the end
of this year we have our first
proof-of-concept Destiny's mission with
networking on the client but no server
architecture and by the end of this year
we've successfully reunited all of the
Rd and gameplay prototypes into a single
main line of Technology this is an
example of what the tiger engine
renderer looks like as it starts to come
in around the middle of 2011 as you can
see artists and designers can try out
their ideas and test levels like what
does the tower look like but they can't
create anything like production content
at this point and that becomes a real
problem 2012 is when all the separate
pieces come together we start to
integrate the client engine with a
service architecture which up until this
point have ended up totally
independently in March art content can
enter full production a new gameplay
system start to reach parity with the
legacy engine so we start porting all of
our prototypes and starting in June the
mission design tools are functional so
actual true game
production can begin this is the point
when we take all of our gameplay
features and then we can write them to
final AP is before this we've had to
port our gameplay features every time we
make API changes from here on out we no
longer have to rewrite any gameplay code
between here and shipping I mentioned
PlayStation 3 engine development started
the previous year by around the late
2012 we were ready to put a ton of
Engineers on just converting every
feature to run on SPU's you know the
PlayStation 3 engine was a huge
achievement took about 25 engineer years
in total over the project I would say
that doesn't count the content creation
costs but by the end of the year we have
the game client integrated with the
network and service architecture running
on both PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360 this
is where we end up around the end of
2012 we can make a representative
experience so take a look at the
difference we've seen in one year
everything is able to come together
really fast in 2013 the engineering team
is able to move to support new gameplay
features for destiny all of our content
teams are in full production we have to
continuously spend time optimizing the
content pipeline to meet the new content
demands from April through November we
bring up the engine on PlayStation 4 and
Xbox one these platforms go from 0 to
about 80% functionality in less than 6
months mostly that's because our engine
features in our content would plan for
them from day one in e3 2013 as the
first public showing of destiny and at
this point it begins scale testing and
automation against both the client and
the service by the end of the year we
have the full destiny experience all
levels or missions or functionality
playable and all platforms 2014 is
post-production engineers are focused on
memory and performance optimization
content creators are building missing
features and polishing the game we bring
all the features up to the shipping bar
on four platforms and go gold and August
so that's kind of a simplified version
of development finally we're done we end
up with a very large project by fire our
biggest the codebase Coxon around 5.7
million lines of code that is including
both the client game agent and tools but
that does not include bungee net does
not include the destiny service
architecture in general this project is
about five times bigger than halo 2
which is the other project that I have
good numbers for and you can notice a
lot of differences in scale
so how do we do against our new core
engine principles we had a lot of goals
for the engine well overall I would say
we develop delivered on about 60% of the
capabilities we were aiming for some of
them ended up better than others so I'd
like a little report card here a lot of
stuff ends up working really really well
like our multi-threading a
cross-platform engine our editor and
tools to touch on some of the points
that aren't so great a layered code base
structure wound up being messier than we
intended it compiles really slowly and
it's actually pretty a big time sync on
our engineering team we probably need to
split the code base up into dll's by
layer which would take a really long
time now given the side of the code base
we now realize we should have done this
up front see if the engine structure and
stick to it that we didn't our
componentized object system is really
really powerful but it is kind of hard
to use for engineers and content
creators our scripting environment works
but it's not really very efficient
either for prototyping or for
implementing production gameplay mostly
this is a consequence of iteration times
and performance and talk about this
later on but the big one is our content
duration times are pretty bad you can be
looking at minutes for a small change in
tens of minutes for a big change now one
of the pillars of the engine right from
the start was meant to be rapid constant
iteration and we struggled with it
continuously through development it's
very very hard to solve this problem
while you're in the middle of
development but we have made big strides
towards fixing it after release I'll
talk about this more later on as well so
we don't really have time for a full
post-mortem that's about as far as I'm
gonna go into it just to recap we
undertook a massive transformation of
our engine we built a lot of features
that are very technically advanced which
is both the good thing and also a bad
thing and it took about one and a half
years longer to build the engine than we
originally thought we thought would be
ready for final game features in
production in into 2010 took us until
the middle of 2012 and like we discussed
we ended up with some great results and
some not-so-great results so now we'll
take a look at some specific lessons
that we learned during this development
process the first lesson is that nothing
is new anymore
remember we were talking about engine
choices we identified that we want to
evolve our existing technology well
there are two main choices here
first is you can try and build these new
components you
within the context of your existing
engine but how would that even work
you're dealing with all of the
complexity of the old code plus all of
the complexity of the new code at once
and that sounds really slow and
inefficient we certainly shouldn't do
that
I know instead what we should do we
should construct a new framework that
stands alone and then we can just take
the pieces we want from the old engine
and pull them across the new AP is that
sounds really amazing and beautiful and
our new engine will be a work of art
it's a trap
the problem we face here is very well
known programmers love to write new code
and it is our favorite thing to do it
colors out judgment in every way so much
so it is very very difficult to make
rational decisions about rewrite versus
extend and even when you are aware of
this emotional bias you are still
subject to it more than you expect so
yeah the standalone approach report our
existing code at is some newly written
framework sounds beautiful it's
incredibly enticing but it is a huge
trap this is not a new concept here you
can see two famous examples of writing
on the subject by Joel Spolsky and
Randall Munroe you should all be
familiar with their work you could form
the opinion based on this that new code
is just never the answer and we are just
doomed to legacy systems forever but
there is another way and that is what we
did with the tiger engine it's gonna
walk you through that now in this
approach which I call the hybrid engine
you start by extracting functionality
from your legacy engine that can stand
alone toolbox type code now you need to
extract and then replace this code the
old code has to be removed
you must reroute the engine to talk to
the new foundation if you don't do this
you are adding too much complexity it's
ok to replace a mature system with some
40% complete implementation at this
point so just as long as you can get the
job done and then come back later to
handle all the edge cases you have to
dip recuit for the sake of simplicity
I'm going to present this process as a
series of sequential stages what really
happens is that all of these two stages
have a very long tail before they're
complete and they overlap with later
stages the next stage is when you start
building your new core engine components
on top of this new foundation layer each
of these components is going to follow
the new engine rules internally and
communicate with the legacy engine
through shims that allow it to use the
old data formats and old principles just
as an example your new render it needs
to be able to draw legacy objects even
if it just shows them as colored spheres
and your new object system has to be
able to collide with both the legacy
environment format and your new
environment representation this is
really really hard on this approach as
such a lot of complexity in such a lot
of time we spent over a year in this
stage and progress just felt very slow
emotionally it felt about five times
slower than it should
but eventually we started to get
traction and the new component started
to be completed and then connect
together that brings you to the next
stage this is exciting but you can see
real progress you can run the engine and
mode where these new systems are all
active they all have primary control
they're all talking to each other so the
new renderer is displaying new
environments with a new object and
physics system and you can start
building very basic new content at this
point you need to retain the ability to
switch at runtime between the two modes
one with the new systems which you're
only able to run test con at this point
and one with the legacy systems so you
can run a legacy map that uses the old
renderer old environments and the old
object system the reason that's
important is because all your gameplay
prototypes for your new game are built
in this legacy environment they rely on
the legacy gameplay content and again no
surprise this is really painful because
you have to keep both modes running for
longer than you really want in this next
stage now that you have the core engine
up and running your engineers can start
to go wide and write new features that
are exclusive to the new engine AP is
for example a new effects system or a
new streaming system they're written on
top of the new object system entirely
and they never had to know anything
about the legacy object system this is
where your progress starts to actually
take off now at this point a lot of the
legacy engine components will be
difficult and use but they still exist
in the code base you can start removing
them if you have time but also there are
likely to be lots of features the legacy
engine you want to continue using into
the future so you have to keep around
some pieces just so these things can
compile and just so they continue
working your priority here is to reduce
total system complexity by ripping out
old dead code prioritizing the pieces
that are adding the most complexity to
your total engine but you have to deal
with diminishing returns as you do so
because ripping out old code is
competing with building new features at
some point you'll dip rated enough of
the legacy systems you can just make a
surgical strike and go and remove all of
the old code maintaining only the
highest level game layer that you want
to keep that's great it reduces your
build times it keeps your maintenance
costs low and you can start to feel good
about your codebase again well we didn't
reach this stage yet I'm not sure if we
ever will honestly the important point
to note here is that you are looking at
a flexible path at every stage along the
way
you have options you can choose what is
pragmatically right for your project in
the next three or six months you're
continuously able to make cost-benefit
choices about where you spend your time
contrasting that with building a
standalone engine than having to make a
hard switch over at some point in the
unknown future so this hybrid approach
took about three and a half years and
some of the stages along the way we're
really difficult and took a lot longer
than we expected
we changed almost all of the core rules
of our engine while working with over
five million lines of code now code base
and we had to preserve critical gameplay
functionality all the way along the way
that could not be broken now you pay a
massive tax for this flexibility we
don't have a control group that built
the same engine from scratch except
maybe the Far Cry team might be an
example we don't really know exactly
what we gave up but we think our engine
development was maybe two or three times
slower than it emotionally felt like it
should have been but ultimately all the
systems in orange here are new for
destiny we both a lot of really advanced
technology that could not have been
built without changing the core rules of
the engine that it relied on the green
components all came from Halo Reach but
they're evolved so much that they're
essentially brand-new and in blue or the
components that we preserve from Halo
Reach and then extended to make the new
game of destiny the two important
components in blue here of the
networking stack and the game layer each
of these is a critical investment that
we just could not afford to lose overall
this was a very very long process we
spent a lot of engineering time doing it
but ultimately I don't know any other
way we could have ended up with the
results that we did now we're going to
start moving into looking at specific
lessons from the development process the
first of these is the idea of shipping
early what I mean by that we already
talked about how the first stage of the
tiger engine process was extracting
low-level code from a Halo codebase and
refactoring it this created a new
cross-platform foundation layer those
responsible for things like files
platform memory management reusable data
structures and a job system for task
based multi-threading well wait a minute
we're also building Halo Reach at the
same time and it doesn't have a job
system that could be really helpful to
take better advantage of the Xbox 360s
multi-tiered computing power so we
decided to integrate the entire Tiger
engine such as it was back into Halo
Reach we replace the foundation layer
underneath
the engine during the middle of
development and this enabled us to use
the new Tiger job system for a few
targeted purposes in Halo Reach
we ended up converting the halo
animation system and part of the object
physics simulation to use it and that
was very helpful to project so this
piece the technology actually shipped
four years before the rest of destiny
back in 2010 well was that a good idea
well as with anything there were costs
and benefits the costs are you have to
take this foundation layer up to a
shipping quality much much earlier than
you otherwise would have to do there's
also an opportunity cost while you're
doing that you're not continuing
development on the rest of the engine
and you know is it really a good idea
while all this code is gonna change
later anyway there are some benefits it
acts as a forcing function on your
engine development you can't dodge away
from this if you need to ship this code
you have to ship it it allows you to
take some risky feature like the idea of
task based multi-threading and prove it
out much earlier than you'd be able to
do with your new engine it allows other
engineers to give you early feedback on
the direction that the engine is taking
remember only a small fraction of your
team is working on this new stuff you
don't want them to feel like they're in
an ivory tower and everybody else's like
throwing Rotten Tomatoes up them and it
can help bring your engineering team
closer together create some camaraderie
with hindsight you know even though all
of this code ended up changing massively
in the following four years this turned
out to be a very important forcing
function I think it was one of the best
decisions we made next we're gonna look
at another lesson this one is about how
you can achieve change in a large
engineering team and this lesson is that
code beats documents so suppose you're
in a large team a large code base you're
trying to change the rules of the engine
in some way well what this means is
you're trying to impose a new contract
potentially on a lot of existing code
and also all the new code that's being
written and you're only gonna be
successful if all of the code
successfully gets converted a partially
converted contract is worse than useless
because then you just end up with
confusion uncertainty and complexity
your engineering team wants to help with
this effort if they don't you have
larger problems it's outside the scope
of this presentation but they also want
to get their tasks done and likely
they're not on the same page about the
goals of the new engine so in this
situation what
this nation development tells us is the
new contract you're trying to achieve
must be enforced by code you can write
about it you can talk about it as much
as you want but without some code
enforcement all that talking just will
not work so here are some examples of
rules that we tried to follow with our
code which were not successful because
there was no enforcement the first all
content errors must be actionable by a
content creator I totally wrote that in
a tentacle design document at one point
well who's going to enforce that
what's the enforcement process going to
be the answer is there was no
enforcement we ended up with a bigger
mess than when we started
our content errors are very hard to
understand next rule everybody should
follow the rules for code based layering
so a foundation cannot include engine
engine cannot include the game layer
initially this was enforced by include
paths within our code base because the
physical structure of the code base does
not allow you to include header files
from higher-level
then at some point you're in development
we moved to a new build system which
didn't have that same header file path a
enforcement what ultimately happened is
that layer violation started to creep in
and they were hard to fix because these
were not just one person in one place
including a header file you're talking
about structural dependencies where some
system depends on a system illegally and
so we failed with that but here are some
successful examples that we did change
across the codebase we're enforcement
helped us the first is this idea that
all data access in the engine has to be
thread safe if you went to bury Genoa's
talked yesterday he talked about this
system in destiny you can see on the GDC
vault as well we built a giant system
that monitors and interacts almost all
of the data access that happens in our
engine and then ensures that that data
access is provably thread safe and
that's great this enforcement was very
successful for us and Milt is hurting
our engine the next rule was no
synchronous i/o well how do we enforce
that we built the api's for the
asynchronous file system usage first and
then we built a synchronous system but
that synchro's call is specifically
marked as unship abble and that means
that if you have to go on write some
synchronous file i/o code it's just not
going to compile in your release build
next example as we said well all the
game code must be deterministic so if
you provide the same inputs to that code
then the codes going to run the same
fashion this enabled input
reproducibility you can provide inputs
the
runs in the same way as it did last time
that's a great benefit to all engineers
and all testers but it only works if
everybody follows the rules and
engineers will not be able to find a
violation in this system just by running
the game as you run the game game works
that's great if you were then to play
back your input and it was
non-deterministic well you detect that
but most engineers don't run the
playback pathway so this example we
ended up enforcing via automated test
gauntlet that runs on every check and
from every engineer and that helped us
impose this successfully so what can we
extract from these examples what does
good enforcement of an engine rule look
like the overall idea is to make
following the rules the easy choice what
that means is you need a code system
that detects anybody violating the rules
and stop it usually that's nicer Schnoor
a build break and this enforcement needs
to work on an engineer's local
development development machine if
possible while they are testing their
code not at some later time on some
build farm ideally you will also have
enforcement that runs as part of your
automated checking tests that way you
can prevent violations from being
checked under the source tree any of
these violations need to report really
detailed information about how to fix it
and not just information for an expert
your audience for this information is a
grumpy programmer who doesn't know
anything about the system that's
complaining at them and they have to be
able to understand what's going on and
be and they have to have step-by-step
instructions on how to fix it otherwise
the experts in the system have to fix
all the violations you do not want them
and sometimes it's just not possible to
fix a violation maybe it's a really
subtle problem maybe the enforcement
system is wrong maybe there's a play
test build tomorrow we just have to
bypass the enforcement temporarily
there's a number of reasons why any of
these enforcement mechanisms need to
have an opt-out mechanism as very very
important point here do not make this a
global opt-out mechanism do not make any
global way to turn off the enforcement
system because otherwise your system
gets checked and turned off and then you
have to find out it got turned off and
then the experts have to get everybody
back down to zero violations before they
can turn the system on again that's why
these opt outs need to be local apply
only to a single violation and has to be
centrally tracked easy to find and easy
to fix the overall message here is trust
but verify your engineering team wants
to do the right thing and if you make it
easy for
you'll have a lot more success at
imposing these kinds of constraints on
your codebase next we're going to talk
about the implementation order of engine
systems any new ancient system depends
on underlying technology suppose that I
am working on a new feature and I depend
on the widget system the Bob is still
working on the widget system and it's
not ready yet as an engineer I have a
couple of options well I can stop my
work and go and help Bob out maybe the
two of us can bring the widget system up
faster and then I'll be unblocked ok
well but designers are depending on my
work and I don't want to slow them down
and also maybe I don't understand very
much about widgets so I wouldn't be
anywhere near as effective as bob is at
writing widget code this is a pretty
common problem and one way it's often
solved is that maybe I'll go and work
around this dependency maybe I'll write
my own shim API that's a new temporary
API I can I can call into just as a
placeholder for Bob's future widget
system or maybe there is a prototype of
the widget system that already exists
and I can use it it's kind of crappy
like a low performance version of it
eventually it'll get removed and
replaced with a later production ready
version either way I can unblock myself
and I can keep writing code and making
decisions about my system and that's
great actually this is incredibly
dangerous
the reason it's dangerous is because you
are then building your system on top of
something that is not real if you don't
have real production code back in your
API you will not know if you are writing
patterns in your high-level code that
are structurally unship abble and can
never be made performant another reason
is that these shims tend to have pretty
leaky abstractions they might have edge
cases or failure modes that will cause
complexity to leak out into your
higher-level system and then maybe
you'll pass that complexity on to other
users of your system but the main reason
is that these shims are just typically
full of incorrect assumptions
assumptions about data structures or
calling conventions or data lifetime and
these traits can propagate incredibly
quickly throughout a codebase the
technical debt that you incur by
removing a shim late can be just
astronomical maybe 10 to 15 times the
cost of just doing the right thing early
on it's very very easy for us as
engineers to underestimate these costs
like stop me if you've heard these
phrases before I totally plan for that
we could have dropped that
whatever is ready or doing the right
thing now we'll take six weeks we don't
have time for that in the current
milestone well my favorite well it's too
late now I guess we just have to make
the minimal changes necessary and then
ship it now we do have some examples in
destiny where shims were effective but
the examples where it failed are really
really bad maybe you don't believe me in
10-15 times is too high I'm gonna take a
look at any one example so you might
remember from earlier that we built a
scripting engine very early on the tiger
project and our goal here was to build
some gameplay script api's on top of the
halo reach engine and then it can do a
bunch of gameplay investigations and
start building this gameplay script
layer in the tiger engine and then we
can port all of these prototypes by
replacing those placeholder engine api's
with the tiger engine when it's ready
sounds hard
and we're gonna have to make a lot of
assumptions all the way up and down this
engine stack we need shims for all of
these things that don't exist yet well
that that's a lot of assumptions but you
know it seems plausible I mean it's not
not a terrible idea right you can build
a scripting sandbox and then convert
that later on and there's such a huge
benefit of preserving all those
prototypes all the way forward in the
future and besides if it's not working
we can just throw away all those
prototypes right well what actually
happened is that all of the engine
dependencies underneath the script
sandbox came online but they tended to
come online out of order so it wasn't
just that the tiger ancient ABI api's
arrived late so you have the script
sandbox and we might replace a shim
somewhere in the stack and then later on
we have to replace it again because
another system underneath that got
rewritten due to another shim changing
underneath that so basically we ended up
writing four separate script compilers
in 2008 2010 2012 and 2014 the details
are not super important and they're
they're kind of hard to quantify like
these numbers aren't really real but the
main point of the slide is just to
convince you guys that I'm really not
kidding that you can get into technical
dead situations that cost 10 to 15 times
what you would naively expect and at
every point along the way we felt we
were making very calm and rational
decisions based on sunk costs and based
on future costs and what we felt was
remaining to be shippable but the future
costs kept creeping up on us because all
of the shims would obscure the structure
of the final shipped system we were
aiming for we always felt we were
actually a lot closer to a shippable
system that we really were and we ended
up kind of bogged down in this vicious
cycle where you have shims that lead to
code in the code churn leads to
complexity through leaky abstractions
and that results in slow iteration times
and poor overall system performance well
okay the obvious question is if you
don't want to do that how can you handle
the situation safely there are some
patents I believe are safe like we
talked about you can just move resources
around I can go and help Bob finish the
widget system or we just delay my system
I can go and work on something else
until bob has written the widget system
and then I'm ready to start now we get
into more complex options I could go and
build a prototype of my system we're not
talking about a game prototype here but
an engine prototype something let's you
understand what the final system might
look like this seems to be only useful
if you can put really tight constraints
on it you have to limit the time that
you spend you have to plan that this
prototype will get thrown away not
ported and there any ideas will be
re-implement in the new system
after the engine dependencies become
available and given those constraints
this does seem to work it is still less
efficient with engineering time than
there's waiting until you can do the
real thing and of course you you can
write a shim to unblock yourself the
trick here is to be absolutely certain
that you can ship this shim if necessary
as a fallback but even then it's still
probably a bad idea I really don't
recommend you do it the next lesson
we're going to talk about is how to
handle content scaling the volume of
source content in your game is hard to
predict ahead of time but it's very
important to try and predict it because
it has a big impact on the scalability
of your content processing pipeline but
one thing we can say for sure it tends
to arrive very quickly one reason for
this is your contents team is likely to
ramp up exponentially as you move into
production particularly if you're part
of a multiple projects you do you can go
from a small number of content creators
to a large number of very very fast
another factor is the complexity of
individual assets it's very possible to
build a combinatorial system that has
complexity proportional to for example
models times shaders times permutations
and not really realize that that's what
you've done and your content will go
through several changes and fidelity as
you go from mass out to production and
then from production to
production so for example you add more
shaders put a model may permutations
model you can end up with really large
increases in Asset complexity they
happen across your whole content tree
very very quickly the last reason is the
artists tend to travel in packs at least
at Bungie our audits are very very good
at bringing a whole team to bear on a
single experience and making a look
amazing
like an e3 demo something like that this
also can increase your asset complexity
very quickly so all these factors
multiplied together to do something like
this everyone raise your hands if this
gap graph gave you a flashback to some
disaster in your career Wow less than I
thought
okay just like climate change this is a
problem our monkey brains are very bad
at solving by the time you are in the
danger zone it is already too late to
fight these trends you are stuck trying
to mitigate and you're unable to keep
pace with the incoming volume of content
that means every engine must think about
this problem ahead of time and try to
get ahead of the curve the big problem
here is that content scales super
linearly but ancient capability tends to
scale sub linearly many operations used
in graph systems scale is order n log n
which is not great you can try to use
distributed computing but you quickly
run into Amdahl's law so what you have
to do is aggressively design your
pipeline to scale linearly that means
decouple your content types and try to
break dependencies between them
sometimes you may have to choose kind of
a dumb content pipeline and push a bit
more work to the runtime engine or to
the content creator the goal is to keep
several types of content isolated from
one another and prevent crosstalk that
may not be convenient for your content
creator you may be able to solve that in
your source editor environment but it's
usually the right thing to reduce the
overall system complexity another
strategy is that sometimes you can get
your content creators to accept the
partial workflow for example rather than
implementing an expensive incremental
lighting update system maybe just give
your artist of the choice of whether
they want to bake light maps where they
want to use the old ones all of these
strategies basically boil down to trying
to avoid global optimization problems
because they don't scale many of these
principles are the same principles that
govern server scalability you must look
at your content processing pipeline and
think about how can we scale this out
rather than into scale up these single
points of global optimization
if you can do that you can stay closer
to closer to a linear process and
capability increase and that means you
can spend more of your time in a sweet
spot underneath the content curve so now
let's finish up by talking about the
epic struggle against software
complexity so far I've touched on this
number of times in passing but really is
the entire theme of this presentation
software complexity manifests itself as
this feeling that it's kind of hard to
get things done I'm not talking about
technical debt here which is bad code at
the leaf of your engine but rather
structural complexity one of the source
of this complexity will was just adding
engineers I have this kind of principle
that number of lines of code is equal to
number of engineers times number of
months and it has almost no relation to
the problem you actually ask them to
solve in the first place
modern engines also have many
specialized systems for example the
Destiny shader system about a hundred
times more lines of code than the halo
shade of system that shipped back in
2001 another big source of complexity is
that in the modern engine some systems
are never really finished and that
incurs attacks on everything around them
due to edge cases error handling or just
clumsy api's another source is a lack of
inspection tools what that means is if
something goes wrong you have to dive
deep into all this complexity which
slows down your ability to understand
what's going on all of this complexity
can lead to a positive feedback loop
right it's hard to get things done you
just have to get your code written as
quickly as possible you don't have time
for the right way that leads to more
complexity your iteration speed is slow
so you make a smaller number of large
chickens that means you have fewer
chances to increment alehrer fine your
code which leads to more complexity and
so the cycle just continues around and
around unless you are continuously
paying attention of this you can get
stuck in a very inefficient State how do
we deal with this we deal with this by
making sure we have a focus on
architecture we have a really defined
software architecture yet but I believe
that we can software architecture is the
large-scale structure of a code base
okay
well but what's strong architecture this
is structure that controls complexity
within your engine it's a set of
interfaces that allow you to insulate
systems from each other's implementation
details it's the idea of a watertight
abstraction rather than a leaky
abstraction
heids internal complexity and presents a
simple outward reliable wrapper to other
engine other other components it's a set
of utility technologies that let you
quickly understand what's going on
within your engine you know I could go
on and on this is well-documented we all
kind of know what strong architecture
looks like but what's the benefit of
strong architecture what doesn't really
let you build features faster well it
does a little bit because iteration
speed it doesn't really increase the
quality of your game except a little bit
again because of iteration speed but
what it lets you do is tackle big
problems problems that would otherwise
be out of reach entirely if you tackle
big problems without having strong
architecture you wind up drowning and
complexity and unable to complete your
feature no matter how long you spend
doing it there's just one problem with
this like we already established
changing the rules of a codebase is hard
and code bases are really large these
days we're working with gigantic code
bases under shifting requirements and
constant pressures of expediency and we
don't get to press the reset button
these investments in our code are just
too large to throw away so what I
believe is this means it is literally
impossible for us to design and then
build large-scale strong architecture
from the ground up not anymore those
days are now behind us now we are no
longer software architects what are we
we are software gardeners
we work in environments that are messy
they are full of sprawling rich life and
complexity we spend our days grappling
with the limits of our ability to affect
change we don't really get to build new
things anymore but there is still a joy
to be found in the work and so I say
make pragmatic decisions work with what
you have stay in the moment but keep one
eye on the future and don't be afraid to
make big investments be brave when we
look back on destiny we built a lot of
great technology and shipped a pretty
great game we knew from the start that
it would be tough and it was but it was
absolutely worth it I firmly believe you
cannot build something great without by
staying safe anyway I hope that our
experiences can help all of you and
taking on your own big challenges and
then completing them successfully thanks
a lot for listening